PBS has always done their best to keep
us happy they have been great they've
been so nice to us and they're always
coming up with new ways to make us feel
happy and comfortable here and today
they have gone a step further this blew
me away but check it out Andy I don't
know if you heard anything about this
but you and I are now getting waiter
service here on the show during the show
our own weight we get our own waiter
here on the show than I'm told that we
can order anything we want they gave us
these menus right here and it's
absolutely incredible let's bring our
new waiter out Greg you crazy you here
great how are you gentlemen this I have
to say Craig this is fantastic I can't
believe we get to do this absolutely
what can I get for you guys I'm gonna go
first I'll take a dirty gin martini use
Haman's reserve if you can and I'd like
a bottle of Gerolsteiner sparkling water
with lemons and line and then let's see
I'll start with the saffron-infused
lobster risotto okay you want to write
this down no it's it's all up here all
right all right then I'll have the Talia
tell pasta with the oxtail ragout and a
glass of the 93 Bruno Geass cofell vada
Reserva
I know that one got it okay and you're
sure you don't want to write this down
I'm absolutely sure how about you mr.
O'Brien okay guess I'll start off with
an old-fashioned with basil Hayden's
bourbon and exactly three splashes of
orange bitters right
I'd like the red endive shaved fennel
and parmigiano Reggiano with the anchovy
date vinaigrette on the side on the side
right I'd feel better if you wrote this
down it's not necessary okay
then I'll have the hand stamped marjoram
infused egg pasta with braised veal
along with a side order of Brussels
sprouts and pancetta sauteed in Ligurian
olive oil and for wine the vino nobile
Sanji of a C 2011 from Toscana got it
all set all right do you want to repeat
that back to me I don't I want to put
these orders in I'll be right back with
your food guys
that guy's incredible he's amazing
I didn't get any of that this is my only
option big pants maybe you should write
it down
[Music]
there were six things very wrong with
that sketch look for them he put on a
wig before he killed himself suicide
with a handy suicide there's a cliff
right outside our studio there sure is
interesting alright and this is all four
bic pen which is paying us anything felt
like a pan add alright
you